З початком наступу російських військ з півночі цей правий берег Київського моря у лютому опинився під окупацією.
Кілька сіл росіяни не контролювали. Та люди тут були відрізаними від світу.
Це їхня смерть тут. Глухий кут. Ми живемо в такому закабанчику, що тут далі або по воді, або нема куди.
Якщо б їх тут затиснули, то їм би тут все було. Вони би тут і залишилися.
За кілька тижнів ізоляції у місцевих почали закінчуватися харчі, багатьом потрібна була медична допомога.
Тоді рибалки вирішили влаштувати переправу на інший, вільний берег Київського водосховища.
Все почалося, коли стало питання: у селі була вагітна жінка,
якій був призначений термін і треба було, щоб вона народжувала у лікарні.
Крига була така - де по 3, де по 5 сантиметрів. Цей рейс був дуже небезпечний. Але доїхали туди.
Першим рейсом по воді поверталася до своїх рідних Анжела.
Жінка приїхала у Страхолісся за день до повномасштабного вторгнення і потім не змогла виїхати із села.
Бо російські війська вже стояли в Іванкові.
Дванадцятого березня ми якраз виїжджали з цією вагітною дівчиною. Ми були перші, кого вивезли.
Страшно було. Ми буквально розбивали лід. Але трималися якось, підтримували одне одного.
Рибалки щодня ризикували, бо могли загинути від кулі чи штормової хвилі.
Та сотні людей з навколишніх сіл тікали від окупації і просили про допомогу.
Он там дача Януковича. І ота вся сторона була під кацапами.
Ми переїжджали на ту чернігівську сторону отак по прямій, а потім отак стороною вже на Ровжі.
У цей човен клали три матраци, там були такі не нові, клали, щоб було людям хоч якось.
Сідало до 16-ти людей.
Спочатку вивозили людей, які потребували якогось медикаментозного лікування. Вагітних, дітей, старих людей.
На вільний берег вони вивозили людей, а звідти забирали гуманітарну допомогу і постачали в ізольовані села.
Там, на лівому березі, їм допомагав Костянтин - власник риболовної бази.
Тільки з села Страхолісся та інших було реально лише з адресними посилками орієнтовно 70 тонн гуманітарки передано.
І десь 2, може, трохи більше тисячі людей з того берега.
Але набагато було більше гуманітарки, людей з боку Сухолуччя, Толокуня, Ясногородки, Димера переправлено.
Під час гарної погоди рейс тривав 40 хвилин лише в один бік.
У такому ритмі рибалки рятували людей майже місяць.
Найбільше водних переправ зробив Олександр - до трьох щодня.
Я їздив на ту сторону, де орки були, але вони там не зайшли в одне село.
І там був у нас визначений білий балкон, ми туди під’їжджали і теж звідти забирали людей.
Перевозили спочатку на Страхолісся маленьких дітей.
16 людей я тоді перевіз звідти за одну ходку, взагалі грудних дітей з Пиляви.
А вночі перевозив із Костіної бази зброю, боєкомплекти та добровольців у тил до росіян - для зачистки.
До мене приїхала "Карпатська Січ". Заїхало понад 100 людей.
Ми з усіма хлопцями вже були навчені, людей возили.
Організували все, допомогли знайомі та деякі мої човни були - і це все перекинули нагору до Білорусі.
Спочатку вечорами, ночами возили. Потім вночі іноземний легіон супроводжували, багато було.
Спочатку я розвідку завіз на Нептун, у цей же день вони взяли Нептун під свій контроль.
Друге квітня. Феєричне завершення операції "Нептун". Слава Україні! Героям Слава!
Рибалки зізнаються: було страшно.
Часом серед Київського моря переставав працювати мотор і вітер ніс човен у плавні до росіян.
Та вони відчували свій обов’язок - допомагати людям.
Другий раз стріляло, другий раз ракети тут над нами, то літаки. Страшнувато було, звичайно.
Ви можете собі уявити, як було їздити? Мені дружина каже: "Воно тобі треба? Ти один тут в селі? У тебе дитині 4 роки".
Ні, кажу, мені треба.
Вивозячи їх, ми знали, що ми робимо погано оркам -
це менше заручників, це менше потенційних постраждалих від чогось такого.
Там що воно буде, як вони зайдуть у села - хтозна.
Стимулювали виходити на воду і перелякані очі дітей.
З ізольованого Страхолісся рибалки вивезли маленьку Аню.
Дівчинка жила там із бабусею, поки батьки працювали у Києві.
У пробний рейс поїхала вагітна, а вже в другий рейс поїхала моя дитина.
Було дуже страшно насправді, поки її везли.
Я не можу передати словами, що я відчувала, поки її везли.
Мене віз дядько Толя - це мій друг, який дуже любить рибалку, у нього хороший човен і він дуже довго мене віз.
Мене накрили одіялом, щоб мені було нехолодно.
Я приїхала на інший берег і сказала військовим: "Слава Україні! Героям Слава!"
Крім щоденних переправ, рибалки ловили рибу, роздавали її жителям навколишніх сіл та возили у будинок літніх людей.
Відсиджуватися вдома не могли і намагалися зробити свій внесок у спільну справу.